hey welcome to daily life I have titled
having two of my videos game life now
how do you feel about it hey we need to
work on your daily life format what's
wrong I have a beginning a middle and an
end
ghost and Elias around like 10 to 15
minutes edit out all the boring stuff
you do not that's very true
okay shots fired
I mean like boring like I know what you
mean that we're having a conversation I
edit out that little space not clean so
that makes the boring thing okay I'm not
saying that they're boring I'm saying
like I spend way too much time editing I
think your problem I'll give you another
money no I think you're doing the likes
of Brabant a bit here this pigeon is
clearly where to Starbucks and we're
heading to Las Vegas we plan on going to
see Britney Spears she sprained her
ankle so no we're not doing anything
wrong no we are over a year yeah we are
winning lots of money and the fight is
going on and we're meeting JB and Ed and
they're going to some Elvis thing I'm
not even sure what they really will find
out so the road trip was started jb here
hello got ed here we've already
introduced we have we had it should we
call you mr. Sheffield Matt Matt like
man I mean I guess you can use the shot
of thing there's a Chipotle and in and
out next to each other let's go to
Chipotle who's still thinking yeah hey
should we use the Apple watch app to
order it yeah burrito button Loreena
button we're here we made it thanks for
driving GB
what's gonna be amazing view and they
knew you were here look at this view mmm
I definitely didn't get a do the view
upgrade you
you get it now he's gonna hold on Fox
you guys can't she's doing up in the
same distance it's not the same you're a
senior too hard to human that's true so
show the frets the prints the print the
form R if you're gonna Apple watch
you're gonna hit your head on this
oh my god Wow that was great medicine
this road trip is taking us a really
long time to get home we've made several
stops we're nowhere near where we need
to be we're never gonna get home we're
at the alien fresh jerky not sure what
this means what are we doing here I'm so
scared by this thing moved
we're trying to go around a really bad
accident happen yeah I don't know
god bless and we did